a través de su abogado
banon pues ha dicho que simplemente no
puede responder a la solicitud de
información que le está haciendo este
comité de la cámara de representantes
porque el ex presidente de donald trump
apeló a su fuero presidencial sin
embargo lo que están diciendo expertos
legales expertos constitucionales en
washington es que banon no hacía parte
de los asesores principales del ex
presidente de donald trump el día de la
toma el capitolio el 6 de enero de este
año banon de hecho dejó la casa blanca
en agosto del 2017 años antes de lo
ocurrido el 6 de enero y que por ende no
se extienden los beneficios del fuero
presidencial al que apela el ex
presidente trompa además pues hay que
recordar que el ex presidente de trump
antes precisamente de salir de la casa
blanca había perdón algo así ve en vano
le dio el perdón presidencial por un
crimen de estafa al que se le acusaba
formalmente active en vano si entonces
en este caso de la información que le
solicita el congreso avaló en el
departamento de justicia procede
entonces a las cosas llegará la
acusación ya formal contra el ex asesor
de el ex presidente donald trump pues
entonces va no tendría la opción de
apelar y lo que muchos expertos dicen es
que esto podría irse a muchos años de
juicio y al final pues no se conocería
esa información que banon debe compartir
y también diario vamos con nuestro
corresponsal cristóbal vázquez sobre lo
que buscan tanto demócratas como
republicanos con la investigación de los
hechos de aquel 6 de enero y esto nos
decía pues es que hubo recordemos cinco
policías cinco personas muertos el 6 de
enero y más de 140 oficiales de la
policía también agredidos y afectados
entonces lo que buscan los demócratas es
justicia es saber aclarar quién es el
responsable intelectual de estos hechos
de la marcha que llegó esta tarde al
capitolio y tram
quebró las puertas quebró las ventanas
logró entrar al capitolio y trató de
atentar contra la vida de muchos
congresistas
por otra parte banon y los republicanos
los analistas en washington dicen que lo
que buscan es pues seguir asumiendo ese
rol de víctimas seguir diciendo que son
los demócratas que es el estado el que
sigue acusando los a ellos para poder
agrandar está figura de martín y seguir
pues creciendo más ese apoyo que tienen
con sus seguidores